you knew you were gonna be a rapper at
nine huh yeah i wrote my first lyric at
eight a lot of profanity
but not profanity in words just in ideas
i was talking about
a woman with big uh you know
[Music]
hey this is bob odenkirk yeah this is
bobby diggs aka davissa
[Music]
and we're doing the wired complete
interview
auto it's auto complete check that out
auto complete
thank you you do a board rizza okay so
bong bong
here we have what lizza
okay oh man what a bad pill this is you
know man
this is auto complete and that's we're
going to complete it there you go
what was liz's first rap name my first
rap name
is pretty embarrassing it was actually
called
baby d because i was the youngest of the
diggs brothers
and so i just had a name baby d
did your brothers rap no my brothers
didn't rap my brother devine dj'd
i was nine years old so i was like i'm
baby d and the baby digs
i i probably started writing comedy
sketches around nine
wow which is what i did for most of my
career you know write comedy
short pieces and i i remember getting my
mom's typewriter
because i thought that was more
professional and writing a pretend
commercial for toothpaste
that's crazy what that kind of confirms
for me bob is that the artistic nature
of who we are it shows up early in life
we're lucky to have that next one here
we go what is the rhythm
real name real is a big word but
you know because rizzy is real but my
mother named me
robert fixed shovel diggs
here's the next one ladies and gentlemen
what did wizards study
i studied many uh different philosophies
and religions you know started off of
course as a christian baptist
i got the chance to come across islam at
an early age
come across the teachings of buddhism at
an early age martial arts and kung fu
and
then that led to japanese swordplay and
i just continue to study knowledge is
the foundation of all things and i
continue to
add to my knowledge and from uh
hip-hop lyricists i needed to be a actor
how about that
what is wizard new movie i'll say i
won't say that it's wizard's new movie
it's my buddy bob ottenkirk's new movie
but it's called nobody all right and
it's the bomb bomb okay and i'm in it as
well
and it's a blast and you're gonna enjoy
it and i'm not selling you something
you know i'm telling you something can i
do a page yeah let's see what you got
there
okay it's bob owen kirk a lawyer no are
you kidding me
i no but i mean god bless the lawyers we
need lawyers and we need people in
politics we need
everybody to do everything as as well as
they can
is bob odenkirk colorblind yeah i'm kind
of colorblind it's sad
my wife always ridicules me for it but i
think i have trouble with like orange
and red and
pink and stuff in that range
uh is bob odenkirk a canadian no i'm not
i love canada
i've loved going there we shot nobody in
winnipeg
and it was the perfect city it was a
perfect city beautiful city
is bob odenkirk on cameo no i don't
really
it sounds like too much work is bobble
and kirk related to kevin costner no
but i have pretended to be him in comedy
sketches
is bob odenkirk related to steve odukirk
i probably am uh steve steve ottakirk
is a uh comedy writer and uh he's
written some great movies
he was uh chum of uh jim carrey's for
years they worked together they probably
still are friends
and he's a really nice guy i met him one
time and he looks like
he could be my brother but we're
probably distant cousins
is rizza a scrabble word
it should be okay i don't know if it is
but
i would put it on the board and see what
happens it's legit
yeah it's legitimate you made it legit
it was a genius
that i can't answer i'll leave that to
the people but i do got a cousin
named the genius he's part of wu-tang
clan they call him the gizza
related well there you go yeah josh is
my cousin
and he's the one that introduced me to
hip hop is rizza
related to scissor no i'm not related to
sizza
she's a beautiful young lady that i had
a chance to meet early in her career
and uh did some music with her is wizard
in
the mandalorian no just because i got a
big forehead don't mean i'm in the
mandalorian is one of those
all right don't do that to me north star
trek
is rizzo still alive alive and well
okay i'll do this what bob what is bob
odenkirk doing now
it's pandemic time folks i'm not doing
much i'm writing
all kinds of different tv shows things
that make me smile
writing some stuff with my kids a kid's
book of poetry and
drawings with my daughter and i wrote a
really silly
audible podcast with my son what is bob
owen kirk known for
uh well i'm going to be known for nobody
because it's a cool movie
and if you like action you're going to
see a lot of it
what is bob odenkirk like i'm kind of uh
intense i go i go hard at stuff and a
little hard to
uh talk to because i'm kind of
preoccupied in my mind all the time
but that's true of a lot of writer type
people i started as a writer and that's
really where my head is at
i can't define bob more better than bob
but i would say
he's intense i got that from my dad my
dad
who was kind of a not my favorite person
on earth but
he had this intensity that came
so fast i use it for acting he used it
to
uh torture the people around him but i i
feel like
i did inherit that and i try to use it
for good
yeah and i would just say i noticed that
that kind of
laser beam focus like to get into
something
you gotta narrow yourself and and and
hold that
intensity as a fellow you know artist
i see that in you man seen it and enjoy
to play with you with it actually
thank you man thank you what is bob owen
kirk's nobody training i trained for
two years with my good friend daniel
bernhardt you know him from all kinds of
performances on screen he's a great
action stunt
actor you might also know him from the
big fight in uh
atomic blonde that he has with charlize
theron
in the apartment what did bob odenkirk
write
i wrote for saturday night live i wrote
for my own show mr show i wrote the
sketch that everybody loves that chris
farley did called the motivational
speaker i wrote that for him at second
city
i read a lot of comedy and now i've been
writing drama
coming from second city did you start in
chicago
was it yeah wow that's crazy that's the
foundation right there i'm like a you
know yeah yeah a lot of great people
there and uh
i was surrounded by great funny people
and a great
attitude towards it all like which is
that the work is what mattered like you
live in a city like chicago when you
start there
you don't think quite so much about
making it big
you just think about being good at what
you're doing and doing something new and
fresh
i'm a fan of of the show of the history
of it so i didn't pick one and one
together but now i got it
so thanks for that for helping us in
that world
and i'm gonna pick this one up here this
is a does this is gonna be dangerous
okay
does rizzo play chess yes that's the
easy one i like that easy one
does have a phd in hip-hop
okay they don't you can't get that in
school you just got to live it so i have
a phd in uh
from the school of street knowledge
does rizzo watch anime yes i love anime
i would actually mention some anime
names but we won't we won't go through
the clearance process
of all that does wizard have tattoos i
didn't believe in tattoos
but i do have one tattoo on my left arm
it's the wu tang w
with my name engraved in it because i
will give my left arm for wu-tang clan
does wizard no martial arts i think we
all know martial arts because
it's just a form of repetition and
practice in your art so whether you're
doing it in kung fu style karate style
sore style or just acting it's a martial
art to it you know what i mean
so i feel that all artists are martial
artists
in some capacity that's cool it's a
discipline that you use your mind
and body together to do something and to
kind of
get deep into something and i do think
acting can be like that
can be like a martial art for sure how
old is bob odenkirk i'm 50 oh bob
odenkirk's son my son's 22.
i'm 58 how old is bob owen kirk i'm 58.
how tall is bob owen here 510.
how nice is bob odenkirk i try to be a
nice guy
i really make an effort because i think
i was uh
i wasn't the nicest guy when i was
younger i was kind of
like i said i was kind of locked in my
head and it makes you
kind of distracted and you can come off
as uh
rude or kind of disconnected and
i wish i hadn't done that i i think
every single person you meet you try to
give them some attention and
try to recognize where they're at i know
you're my big brother here but
that's natural because i was the same
way you know you go back and listen to
my first album 36 chambers
i was against the world i didn't care
who you are what you were it's just an
attitude that that happens in life i
think i think
people are going to feel it at some
point in life and if you could evolve
past it uh but still maintain it uh it's
a beautiful thing that goes what you
said that's
that's the intensity but you're a nice
guy with an intense nice guy how about
that
yeah i think you're right man it's
somehow you gotta
retain your perspective your point of
view as an individual
and a critical perspective but you have
to become
more sympathetic to the condition the
human condition
as you go how did bob odenkirk
meet rizza on this movie i was very
thrilled to hear that rizza would
participate and play my brother and uh
and it was a joy to work with you bobby
and uh
and to watch him work because you've
done this
way more than i have you know your way
around an action set
and you look great in this film and i
can't thank you enough for
for being a part of it i know i said
that i'll keep saying it well bang manga
is mutual brother it's mutual
bobby is a really
unique person and and the real deal when
it comes to being
a an artist and a person who's living in
the moment a lot of people who
if you'd been in wu-tang clan all you
would do
is celebrate the days of your
and he's always on to something new
in a very serious uh committed way and
it's in its
inspiration i see you as a as a
renaissance man and and a serious one
not a dilettante but a person who
approaches each thing with uh solemnity
and seriousness thank you brother thank
you i'm not good at compliments i tell
you that i'm over here
but and what i did learn today from you
though is something that's uh that was
beautiful
when you said that you wrote your first
comedy skit at the age of nine
as an artist i've been looking to other
artists and see what common denominators
that we have because hearing what you
said it helps me
to continue that philosophy you know i
talk to other my buddies in art and i
will always hear something like wait
that was
the same thing because something's in
common so that was a great revelation
for me so thanks for sharing that
you got it man it's great talking to you
great seeing you again respect guys
you